bom dia bom pessoal eu tô aqui
emocionado primeiro por vocês é muito
importante ter um público bom e se vocês
vieram aqui pra ver um monte de coisas
legais que a gente pode fazer na vida
então ele estava de manhã
espero que fique marcado na vida de
vocês eu sou mais um dos que estão aqui
compartilhando pra gente é muito
importante estar aqui junto com vocês né
mas eu não posso chorar eu sou de são
paulo já está economizando água de tudo
quanto é jeito não dá mais pra vocês têm
água aqui gente
foi nos lugares aqui todo mundo
oferecendo um copo de água eu vou ficar
mal acostumado quando chegar em são
paulo novamente mas tudo bem o que eu
vou falar hoje não é nada novo
não é nada novo só que tudo que é
simples a gente deixa de observar porque
a gente já sabe a acha que já sabe
e quando você acha que já sabe você
deixa aqui no meio de lado e vai tentar
ver outras coisas da vida mas um simples
é onde tudo começa
a vida é simples assim e eu começo
falando do homem das cavernas é tão
antigo que vocês podem ver que essas
pinturas que aconteceu com o homem das
cavernas tinha um significado muito
maior do que a gente acha
talvez a a acesa uma das maiores ou se
não a maior descoberta do homem
o desenho é uma coisa instintiva por
isso que tá com um homem das cavernas
o que aconteceu naquele momento o ser
humano ficava muito muitos problemas
muitos problemas pra viver para
conseguir ver talvez uma pessoa aqui
chegasse a ser mais velha 30 anos já
seria considerada velha não tinha plano
de saúde àquelas coisas então as pessoas
morriam antes
pensem bem essas pessoas elas tinham que
sobreviver no de um modo muito rústico e
1 30 anos você pode morrer ter um filho
de três anos ou cinco anos
essas crianças como que elas iam
aprender as coisas da vida como elas vão
poder sobreviver porque os grupos
quando tinha uma criança que sobrava
morreu os pais e sobrava
eles geralmente deixava o meio de lado
que era mais uma uma boca para sustentar
e ainda não estava numa produção ampara
pra conseguir o seu próprio sustento
depende muito dos outros como fazer pra
passar o ensinamento por uma criança tão
pequena como fazer o ensinamento virar
alguma coisa muito mais forte e que
iniciar se todo esse processo pra gente
chegar nos dias de hoje é claro história
em quadrinhos aquela seqüência de como a
caçar um tiro e de como fazer as coisas
de como dominar o fogo de como fazer
sexo tudo isso começou a entrar nas
paredes porque teve um cara começou a
desenhar o que que eram essas paredes
das cavernas
as primeiras bibliotecas o que acontece
com as bibliotecas
elas têm todo o conhecimento para as
pessoas acumularem mais conhecimento
então aquele negócio falar boca a boca
na época do homem das cavernas quando
entrou o desenho mudou essa relação às
pessoas começaram a absorver mais a
partir de alguma coisa que já estava
fixada quando fixar na parede quando
fixa no papel em qualquer lugar e aí a
humanidade começou a evoluir ou evoluir
alguns pensam mas começou a acumular
conhecimento
a principal razão da gente ter evoluído
no conhecimento pelo menos história em
quadrinhos é uma linguagem que às vezes
a gente acha que é para a diversão é uma
linguagem que a gente às vezes acha que
se ficar lá no banheiro pra lá de vez em
quando e tal
no entanto não podemos jogar fora nada
que seja tão simples e tão fácil de
trabalhar como a gente pretende
trabalhar na educação e na escola uma
linguagem dos quadrinhos é tão rica que
as pessoas não percebem quando a gente
tá lendo uma história em quadrinhos hoje
em dia tanto pode ser
na no computador como pode ser impresso
mas a imprensa é muito importante ainda
a nós estamos interpretando aqueles
personagens
quem tá dando a voz para aquele
personagem a gente quem tá dando
entonação de como ele está falando a
gente é uma interpretação teatral que
acontece dentro da gente a gente não
percebe porque é natural agora qual a
diferença entre essa linguagem a
linguagem do cinema televisão e tudo
mais
é uma linguagem que respeito time de
cada um porque quando você está lendo e
você gosta do desenho se pode demorar um
pouquinho mais se você quer e rápido
você pode ler rápido isso de respeitar o
time é essencial pra você absorveu
ensinamento não é uma coisa que você vê
lá o filme de duas horas e se você não
entender alguma coisa passou a não ser
que você volte e veja novamente tudo
mais mas na história em quadrinhos você
pode curtir
você pode trabalhar do jeito que você
quiser a leitura e tendo essa linguagem
tão forte que tem cinema inclusive os
todos os roteiros hoje são padronizados
lepra
aliás desde ticoop né tem quadris ações
da dos pássaros de coque e tudo mais que
dizer então tem essa linguagem do cinema
como eu falei a linguagem do teatro
literatura artes plásticas hoje desenho
você pode fazer disso uma coisa simples
até algo muito mais evoluído né em
termos de artes plásticas
então você tem tudo todas essas
linguagens dentro de uma história em
quadrinhos é estilista e criam um
personagem você tem que criar roupa
desse personagem então para criar roupas
personagem você por exemplo um super
herói porque aquela roupa toda colada no
corpo né
inclusive com a cueca por fora isso é o
que eu entendo mas aquela roupa toda
colada no corpo é que ele luta então ele
tem uma tecnologia da da roupa e hoje em
dia seu têm assistência aos desfiles que
existem aí de dos grandes estilistas e
tudo mais parece que tiraram de uma
história em quadrinhos aquelas roupas
neta entre nós
então alguém que faz uma história em
quadrinhos ele tem essa coisa do design
também quer dizer história em quadrinhos
é base para você levar todos aqueles
alunos pra várias outras profissões e à
comunicação
é o que nós vamos ver aqui porque o que
eu vou falar agora é base de um livro
que vai sair para o ano que vem estou
fazendo junto com a professora sonia
luyten implantou o curso de quadrinhos
na época a usp na escola de comunicações
e artes da usp nos anos 70
aí ela estudou vários lugares no mundo e
tudo mais vi a gente está tentando fazer
uma fórmula de como as crianças podem
aprender mais qualquer assunto dentro de
uma sala de aula através dos quadrinhos
mais uma coisa importante e passa em
branco para a gente em uma história em
quadrinhos o que a parte mais importante
é a parte mais importante de uma
história em quadrinhos é justamente o
que está entre um quadrinho outro aquela
parte vazia
entre um quadrinho outro porque porque é
aí que faz funcionar o nosso cérebro a
gente não percebe evidentemente está
lendo tranqüilo e tal no seu time mas
quando passa de um quadrinho pra outro
trabalhou-se toda a movimentação dentro
da nossa cabeça só exercícios para o
cérebro é importantíssimo pra você fazer
a a pessoa entender como receber
qualquer ensinamento evidentemente que
quando você pega uma criança e vai pra
passar qualquer coisa dentro da escola
qualquer assunto dentro da escola
essa criança tem um problema para
receber aquilo lá porque ela sabe que
ela vai ser cobrada às vezes vai ter que
decorar e tudo mais que entra para o
lado do cérebro que têm problemas tem um
muro e tudo mais
quando entra na parte onírica e por uma
história em quadrinhos vai ter o outro
lado do cérebro onde tem o prazer ea
importância de servir as campanhas aí
que acabamos ter uma eleição a a
importância de a escola tempo integral
do quadrinho dentro da escola tempo
integral nós vamos ter que fazer as
crianças têm vontade de ficar na escola
senão não adianta né então essa área do
das histórias em quadrinhos é muito
importante para desenvolver isso várias
pesquisas foram feitas com professores
né e uma delas
ah ah ah é a principal é aqui que se
fala do 22% dos professores são
preocupados com a manter a disciplina
hoje em dia aquela relação professor
aluno está muito desgastada os alunos já
não respeitam mais a motivar os alunos
logo em seguida fazer avaliação a 19%
manter se atualizado 16% escolher a
metodologia 10%
então vejam que há esse problema com os
professores pode ser minimizado
utilizando esse tipo de linguagem né é
uma linguagem incentivar como a gente
viu se você está numa situação como a
gente estava que é praticamente o
instinto de sobrevivência pelo instinto
com o homem das cavernas
é uma coisa que está dentro de todos nós
quando vem aquela pessoa que fala pra
mim eu não sei desenhar em uma casinha é
porque ela parou de desenhar todo mundo
desenha o pega uma criança de 1 ano de
idade do lápis pra ela rabisca isso pra
ela é um desenho e nunca dizer não é
importante não é como uma criança está
desenhando e rabisca e fala a desenhar
uma casinha e não é você vê que não é
uma casinha que não pode falar não
desenhou se não uma criança você não
pode falar não logo de cara vai começar
a criar aqueles obstáculos nec pelo
resto da vida pode seguir e aí a pessoa
para falar olha ser muito legal muito
legal desenho mas olha tem esse jeito de
desenhar casinha também né o ensinamento
tem que fazer essas coisas a gente fala
muito não é pra quem tá querendo
entender alguma coisa esse é um dos
grandes problemas dos graves problemas
né
o desrespeito dos alunos aos professores
e tudo mais isso a gente tem que ganhar
esse pessoal de volta né
as crianças estão acostumadas com
brinquedos eletrônicos baixados para a
escola de negócios brinquedos
eletrônicos é o seguinte qualquer
criança gosta de brincar
se você mostrar uma brincadeira para
essa criança e seja alguma coisa que
realmente ela vá se divertir
não importa o que seja pode ser
eletrônico não eu vou dar um exemplo
quadrinhos ou mangá lá no japão é tão
forte
enquanto televisão e veja bem o japão é
um dos países onde mais tem equipamento
eletrônico no mundo como é então que
algumas revistas lá tenho dois milhões
de exemplares por semana
como explicar que lá no japão o jornal
asahi shimbun é um jornal importante lá
do país e outro e humildes timbu xingu
quer dizer jornal
esses jornais cada um deles tem 10
milhões de exemplares dia eles têm algum
lugar que eles fabricam o papel dos avós
não têm lugar para fabricar papel custa
caro então a uma reciclagem por isso que
tudo é feito com papel jornal e tudo
mais uma reciclagem mas é muito
importante vocês vejam só essa coisa de
falar que a criança está abandonando a
leitura pra ir pro eletrônico é uma
falácia é uma falácia
por isso que a gente tem problemas na
educação porque a gente joga fora coisas
que são muito simples
talvez o problema seja o seguinte pra
você implantar quadro na sala de aula
basta papel e lápis coisa que já tem uma
escola e basta você passar alguns
ensinamentos dos professores aplicar
isso na sala de aula custo zero esse é
um problema é um problema às vezes é
preciso gastar dinheiro por causa de
injunções cognitivas e tudo mais para se
fazer alguma coisa enquanto que a gente
pode aplicar alguma coisa simples desse
jeito o lápis e papel no meio de uma
selva amazônica ou qualquer lugar não
tem desculpa nenhuma criança gosta de
desenhar quando ela está desenhando ela
está criando o mundo o que a gente fez
de de experiência em escolas é ficar uns
três meses dentro de escolas e colocamos
exercícios com os professores os alunos
e tudo mais e eles aplicaram em qual em
qualquer área lava geografia história e
tudo mais
a evolução hoje 30 a 5% nos três meses
eu é sonia luyten dentro de escolas
fazendo isso
portanto é algo que a gente tem que
aplicar já
imediatamente dentro das escolas vai
melhorar muito o ensino vai melhorar
muito a relação professor aluno
tem experiência que foi feita na febem
melhorou muito a área da violência o que
você vai trabalhar com alguma coisa que
é um canal de comunicação da criança
quem desenha se sente comunicando
é por isso que os jovens vão fazer
aquelas pichações mas eles querem um
canal de comunicação não é violência não
é nada disso se você cria um canal de
comunicação
você consegue fazer a coisa funcionar
dentro da da sala de aula a gente teve
várias experiências sensacionais
isso vai estar até desenvolvido um pouco
mais no livro oh oh oh que eu queria
deixar para vocês é o seguinte
quadrinhos é uma das soluções para a
sala de aula o professor pode aplicar
facilmente esses ensinamentos e está
trabalhando com algo que qualquer
criança gosta de fazer
simples assim eu gostaria que todos aqui
começarem a perceber um pouquinho mais a
desenvolver um pouquinho mais cada um
inclusive vários professores também que
estão aqui desenvolverem sua sala de
aula não implicará mente estudar um
pouquinho mais e aplicar com as crianças
obrigado